[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report app presented by
fanduel i'm greg ivey alongside
the lovely aaron dolan tonight is game
five
in the bucks hawk series and cabbie
is still on pto i'm jealous of cabbie
my mind's been on the beach all week
with the holiday coming up
yeah it was a heat wave on the east
coast uh the beach
does sound nice and the beach does sound
nice uh we got hoodies to give away we
got nba jerseys to give away and the
first one is going out
when should we give it out there let's
give it out right now
how about now why not i'm in the
comments
let me introduce you guys people that
are new to the show
to this thing right here aaron do you
tell them what this is the handy dandy
ipad
this right here is the handy dandy ipad
this is how you get your jerseys
this is how you get your hoodies i'm in
the comments right now
i got c4s says
middleton double double bucks to win
shout out to uc4sh i don't think i'm
gonna give you the hoodie for that
though but appreciate your comment
appreciate your comments i'm still in
the comments though i'm still here
and i see uh i see alice six
halas six says if trae young doesn't
play lou william is my lou williams is
my best bet
he dropped 21 points and is dropping 36
tonight shout out to you hollis six but
guess what aaron
hollis six repeated his comment like
four to five times
i'm not going to give you the jersey for
that the next person they're getting the
jersey i promise you
here we go last time we're in the
comments for this jersey keeping people
under their seats greg i have
hold on there here we go here we go here
we go here we go i got my guy
not ronald acuna jr he's been here
before he's
always in the show he's won a lot of
hoodies
yeah yet to win a jersey my guy's been
faithful shout out to you not ronald
cuny jr he says middleton scoring 34.
capela with 20 plus rebounds tonight
shout out to you not ronald cooney and
julia you are walking away with the
jersey
let's get to this first segment aaron
let's get to this first segment as you
know
fanduel fanduel is running our favorite
bet aaron
the three by two for every game the rest
of the playoffs
tonight the atlanta milwaukee 3x2
is i think it's up around plus 150 aaron
those are
good good odds uh i need everybody
everybody that is in the comments
everybody that is tuning in to the show
get in the comments and tell me if you
think the three by two will
hit tonight aaron what is your take so
here's my take greg i know that some
bettors were frustrated
after the last group chat show when i
said you just have to take it when
talking about the 3x2
and i'm sorry to upset those people once
again because for the 3x2 you just have
to take it plus 150. it's great boosted
price there
after the buck shot a terrible 21 from
the three-point range in game four i
think we're going to see
positive regression there standing by my
words we just have to take the three by
two
aaron see what you did there is you put
your foot down
oh yeah so i like i like when you put
your foot down you
you you stood on your word you were
riding by three by two no matter what
yeah no matter what and i love that i
love that because that's exactly what i
do
i ride with the three by two no matter
what because
i believe in the what vibes aaron the
good vibes the sunset bags are we still
sunset on this one
sun sunset both go along go along
they're like connected
same thing they're like the same thing
uh let me get into the comments let me
get into the comments though cause the
people are here for hoodies
they want hoodies and i'm here to give
away hoodies yeah i got
hj hazen hj hazen says
the three by two will cash tonight no
doubt shout out to you h.j hazen
you were walking away with a hoodie i
have uh i have one more i have one more
uh length length oh lance alicious
lance alicious aaron lancellicious look
out what a name
what a name you know the homie pj tucker
fittigo beast mode on d
shout out to your take lance alicious my
guy pj tucker does like to
show the clamps on defense i got one
more i'm gonna give away one more hoodie
uh aaron the comments are jumping today
actually the comments are jumping like
i have to actually press the comments in
order for them to stop because they're
jumping so much
uh i have jason wade 13.
jason wade 13 says drew holiday has a
great game
he's calling it now shout out to you
jason wade
you are walking away with the hoodie
like aaron just said he does
need to have a good game no giannis
tonight
no giannis speaking of no giannis aaron
who
is the more valuable player to use i
mean toulouse
is it trey or is it giannis well
is it trey or giannis more valuable to
lose this has been a crazy series
trey is questionable giannis is
officially out for tonight aaron
what i need everybody to do in the
comments get in the comments tell me
which of these players is more valuable
is trey a bigger loss to the hawks or is
giannis
a bigger loss to the bucks and tell me
why
please tell me why the best take is
getting the jersey aaron we saw what
happened
with these two uh in game four we saw
what happened in game four
giannis that was a surprise we did not
see that happening yeah
now that milwaukee has some uh some time
to plan
what do you think for tonight well
considering atlanta won game four
without trae young i would have to say
giannis is the more valuable player to
be lost in the series when giannis left
after hyperextending his knee last game
the hawks went on a 25 to 10 run to end
that third period
that showed us how quickly that team was
discombobulated when giannis was not on
the floor it was almost like the team
panicked
players like drew holiday chris
middleton needed to step up but
it was a tough night all around for the
milwaukee bucks giannis like you
mentioned
is ruled out for this game and
considering the hawks won game four
without trey
and giannis obviously suffered an injury
in that third quarter there i think with
the greek freak being out he will be the
most valuable player to
lose in this series aaron i love that
take
because i absolutely agree with you we
saw it
we saw it in game four yeah the hawks
they're
very lucky i mean they're very lucky
shout out to the gm they're very lucky
to have a backup like lou will
blue will is a walking 18. he's a
walking 18. blue wheel is a bucket
he always been a bucket since he got
into the league that's trae young back
up so if trey young's not in lou wilson
there's no replacement for giannis i
mean they have another antetokounmpo but
he's no giannis i agree so i see i see
giannis giannis as as the more valuable
player
uh if the team wants to lose uh that
player but let me get into these
comments aaron cause they once again
they're jumping yeah let's hear what
they're gonna say about jumping
i'm giving away a hoodie and i'm giving
away a jersey
so let's get in uh i got whis sport no
wi sports 414 aaron is saying the bucks
are going to lose by 10 plus tonight oh
wow
that's a good margin bet
ah take the win margin aaron knows about
those fanduel win margins
actually you guys need to know aaron is
the plug at fanduel i need plugs in the
comments you know
the plugs that you plug into the into
the into the wall plugs because the
aaron is the plug at fandom if you guys
did not know
let me get back into these comments let
me get back into these comments
i got uh name nameless nameless
is rocking with the gif he's rocking
with the giannis gift hopefully it
doesn't
go away you guys can see it there it is
there it is the giannis gift
uh nameless shout out to you you are
walking away with a hoodie i believe
it's time to give out a jersey what do
you think aaron yeah give one out
i feel like everyone in the comments
loves you give a jersey
okay okay let me give out a jersey let
me get out of jersey
i got bad sports takes
bad sports steaks and aaron i just want
to let you know they are
there's a lot of plugs in the comments
they're going you know
they're
says giannis is the guy giannis is the
guy not to lose he is
the power of the team if middleton can't
back up
then you can't replace okay shout out to
your take
i mean i'm giving i'm giving the jersey
shout out to you you walk away with a
jersey bad sports takes
you are walking away with a jersey shout
out to you
aaron um i got a lot of more jerseys to
give away so let's get to this next
segment why don't we
let's get to it let's take a look let's
take a look aaron
at the audience's favorite um
first basket who's gonna score the first
basket let's take a look at the first
basket odds there they are
presented by fanduel awesome odds trey
and my boy clint capela is both listed
as questionable today aaron
what i need everybody to do that is
watching get in the comments please get
in the comments and tell me
who is scoring the first basket aaron
aaron aaron who do you have so i love
this market to be blunt it is hard to
hit the first basket scorers or maybe
it's just me i'm going with chris
middleton plus 420
not just because that's the lowest odds
and technically most likely to happen
considering
when looking at some of those long shots
there but the last time i was asked this
question on the show
i said middleton and it hit so i'm being
very superstitious here
and i'm taking him again overall great
odds though for those wanting to bet
into this first
basket square market let's
go aaron i'm going to piggyback off of
you i'm going to piggyback off you on
sunday i was on
nba bet streams presented by fanduel
which is aaron is the plug for she's the
plug for fanduel guys
i was on nba best streams and i took
clint capela
love it to score the first basket and
guess who scored the first basket
capella so since we're being
superstitious
since we're picking picks that already
won i'm going to follow you aaron i'm
going to rock with my guy
capela he was at the bottom i don't know
if you guys noticed but he was at the
bottom of that list
he was at the bottom plus one thousand
shout out to my guy clint capela i'm
riding
with him for the first bucket but let me
let me get in the comments yeah ten the
one you know i love value aaron yeah
i love plus money and i love value let
me get into these comments and see who
you guys
are riding with i got my boy d geek is
in the house deep geek is in the house
he's riding with john collins john
collins a good one
plus eleven hundred shout out to you
deep geek
uh i'll give d geek a hoodie why not d
geek you're walking away with a hoodie
here we go rip
city reezy rip city reezy gotta go with
brook lopez
corner three for the first basket an
interesting one
throwing a little change up at us right
there and throwing a little change up
shout out to you rip city reezy
you are walking away with a hoodie aaron
the producers just whispered into my ear
and told me to give away a jersey
oh yeah go for it all right we're giving
away a jersey this next person
is going to walk away with a jersey i
got richie richie 21
richie 21 first back burst basket
without giannis
he will try to get it going early and he
gave us a gift of chris middleton
i don't want to rock it there he is if
you guys can see it
there we go there sorry let me get a
little yup there it is
chris middleton there it is uh he's
rocking with chris middleton shout out
to my guy richie
richie 21 you are walking away
with a jersey aaron guess what
what i got more jerseys to give away
more let's keep moving why not
more of them that's how we get people
going on our social
of course they love the jerseys they
love the hoodies
and they also love the vibes and they
love you aaron like they love you too
and you're
always good vibes shout out to people
shout out to the people uh let's get on
because i got more jerseys to give away
we asked you on social and in the app
who is the top scorer for tonight's game
and how many points will they have
uh with all the injuries the odds are
not up yet
but they will be up by game time get in
the comments and tell us who do you
think is going to be the top score
and how many points they are going to
score at the end of the game will dmu
one person we're going to only dm one
person who guessed correctly
and hook you up with a jersey aaron trey
is a game
time decision tonight he's a game time
decision
giannis is out lou will stepped up he
carried that hawks team in game four
with 21 points
and eight assists i talked about him
earlier we're talking about him now lou
will
my guy uh who do you think is going to
be the top scorer
so i think with the two superstars out
of the mix i'm sorry aaron i just had to
get ready you're fine superstars the two
superstars are out of the mix today so
who are you taking
so i think the top score of this game is
going to be chris middleton he's
averaging 21 points in the series which
is
less than players let's say like trey
young who's averaging 33 points in the
series but with giannis out of this game
i think middleton has to step up as he
did
in the previous series against the nets
in game three and six to help the team
and even like he played in game three in
atlanta when he led the team with 38
points
middleton has it in him for the bucks
and i think tonight has to be his night
in milwaukee
i was conflicted i will say with this
question though greg because i thought
that it could be middleton or trey young
if he is ruled in but i also think at
the same time
the hawks know that giannis is out and
they did win that game for without trey
so why
risk his health with that bone bruise
plus it's not a do or die situation for
either of these teams tonight which is
why i'm going to go with somebody
on the box in chris middleton
aaron is locking in chris middleton
she's
locking in chris middleton aaron i'm
going to throw a curve ball at everybody
all right everybody might make fun of me
or they might they might talk about me
for this one but i'm actually going to
rock with my guy danilo galvanari
there's no giannis there's no giannis we
know danilo likes that
high arcing shot uh trey he's
questionable he's questionable to return
um i mean he's questionable to play so
we don't know what trey is going to
bring to the table
although he's trey we don't know what
he's going to bring danilo
i like i like the juju's i like the
vibes i'm pretty sure he's high he's
going to be high
on the list as far as in the odds he
he's been playing well so i like i like
to
roll the dice a little bit i rock with
my guys
uh yeah taking a little risk take a
little take a little throw in a little
dart air but i'm in the comments on the
handy dandy ipad
and once again the comments are just
filled they're they're moving really
fast i got winnie the pooh
says trey with 47 aaron did you watch
winnie the pooh growing up
i did in fact my room when i was born
was a whole winnie the pooh theme
shout out wallpaper and all crazy
i actually i actually stuck the vhs tape
out
people probably in the comments don't
even know what a vhs speaker is
but i stuck the winnie the pooh vh vhs
tape
into my vhs recorder because i put it in
backwards because i used to watch it all
the time
but shout out to you winnie the pooh
shout out to you winnie the pooh
you are walking away with a hoodie uh
everybody's in the comments they're
they're saying i had a bad take
but i love you guys i'm still giving you
guys hoodies uh
in the uh in the comments g money take
us fire shout out to my guy
emmett the goat you're walking away with
a hoodie just for saying my take was
fire brother shout out to you
and then i got i got somebody i gotta
show i gotta show the other side some
love
uh enderman enderman and wade0821
yeah gu tripping galinari ain't going
off
shout out to you guys you both are
walking away with
a hoodie keeping you humble greg
yeah you know gotta stay humble gotta
stay honest
but it is okay guys you guys will see
danilo will have a game tonight
but remember please remember we're gonna
hit
one of you guys up after the game and
hook you guys up with the jersey i got
one more aaron one more jersey to give
away in this last segment
and i'm gonna need um i think i want
gifts this time there
like actual gifts like you guys
investigate i'm just kidding the gifts
the gifts the gifts that are
in the comments you guys give me those
gifts for this next one to
everyone's surprise this atlanta
milwaukee series is tied
to the two we asked you on twitter who's
going to win this series we asked you on
twitter right there
tagged you guys fanduel sportsbook aaron
you are the plug at fanduel sportsbook
and uh here are the results here are the
results
oh kind of surprised by this 62 of
people really
riding with atlanta i feel like that's a
lot i thought it'd be more
closer to 50. i guess not
yeah uh i i'm i'm actually pretty
surprised by this too
uh but aaron um the line has moved a bit
since our since our post so let's take a
look at the latest odds
let's take a look at the latest odds
there they are
uh minus 120 minus 120 now
the bucks are slightly favored yeah the
hawks are now at plus money okay look at
fanduels the guys at fanduels
hooking us up hooking us up get in the
comments and tell me which team is a
better
to win the series is uh bucks is it the
bucks
or is it the hawks you guys tell me
which team is better than win the series
bucks talks
i need some gifts need some gifts in the
comments the most creative gifts is
going to win
aaron what do you think well first off
before i answer that question my advice
for those looking to bet into the series
market you're going to want to bet it
now because these series price odds
can and will shift drastically after
each game so
but to get back to your question greg
every time i count out the hawks
i am proven wrong i was truly shocked
when they beat the sixers now i'm
surprised this is even tied and we're in
this position talking about this
but and a big butt here i think the
bucks are going to be able to pull off
some type of magic in the series i don't
say that
with too much confidence but a potential
game seven at home in milwaukee
will absolutely be an advantage for the
team so i'm gonna go with the bucks
minus 120
because you probably aren't going to see
it at that price again if they win
tonight
aaron is rocking with the bucks shout
out to you aaron you were rocking with
the bucks
let me get into these comments
because not only am i giving away a
hoodie but i'm also giving away a jersey
for the final time i have oh
funny gifts funny gifts yeah let's see
some of the gifts i got
i got rhett m21 john collins you know
the discount double check
aaron rodgers saying crown him right
there
john collins shout out to you rhett m21
you're walking away with me
i got j velazquez 17.
going with the funny gift right here of
the little kid uh being
super excited for the atlanta hawks
shout out to you
uh sports feed sports feeds it's
actually above them you see the bucks
sliding in oh he says the bucks cruising
for the win
see the bucks mass got up here bruising
for the win
uh shout out to everybody i just
mentioned you guys are walking away
with a hoodie aaron i think it's time to
uh give out this jersey yeah go for the
jersey what do you think
last one all right the jersey yeah
jersey last one
i got my boy amen zanares amen zanaris
amen zanares
kevin herder to help lead atlanta win
the east
kevin herter to help atlanta win the
east and look at the gift
look at the gift that's a good one
this is the kid that you know that use
that sings the country i forget his name
but he sings
country songs uh he went viral a couple
years ago uh
hey shout out to you amen you are
walking away with the hoodie but uh
the time has come yeah the time has come
thanks for tapping in
to the group chat presented by fanduel
remember
what you learned today the three by two
is a lot believe in the sunset vibes yes
daniello galinari
is a sleeper lot you guys are sleep
everybody in the comments
you guys are asleep so i need the sleep
emoji in the comments because that's
what you guys are
and and get in there and bet your series
picks before
the lines change get in there and bet
those picks
before those lines change but we'll be
back we'll be back next thursday for
game
one of the finals aaron we're going to
be back for game one of the finals and
guess what
we're going to be giving away hoodies
we're going to be giving away more
jerseys
and something extra special
for the finals you guys have to tune in
and guess what we're giving away
for the finals if you want a hoodie if
you want a jersey
uh we will dm you do not be alarmed we
will dm you
alongside aaron dolan i'm greg ivory
we are leaving the group chat peter
[Music]
you